- [Jay] Good to see
you, it's been a while.
- Yes, it's been a while. Good to see you.
- Now, how's the family?
You've had more kids, how
many kids do you have now?
- I got three kids.
- Okay.
- I have a 26-year-old
and a 12-year-old boy,
the 26-year-old's a
girl, 10-year-old girl,
and a 12-year-old boy.
- Oh okay, so took a little break there.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Yeah, took a little time off.
- Oh gosh, look, the time flies.
Yeah, all right, so.
Wow, okay.
But, like, there's 10 years
between myself and my brother,
so actually that's not that unusual to me.
- Yeah, same with my sisters.
They are eight and 10 years older.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- And of course, we were all planned.
- Oh yeah.
Well, I can't tell you what
my father said about that
'cause this is daytime television,
but yes, we were not planned.
- Yeah, not planned.
Now, any signs that the children
are going the "Jackass" route?
Has the gene literally
fallen from the tree?
- Well, luckily-
- [Jay] Hit them in the head, you know.
- Luckily, my daughters,
that gene didn't get passed down to them.
They're so, you know,
girls are just smarter than boys
and I don't have to worry about them,
but my son is just like my father.
So he's got that funny
look in his eye, and yeah,
so I have to worry about Rocko.
- Both pupils in the same
eye, that kind of thing?
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.